foreign
let's go to rob in Miami Florida Welcome
to Miami what's up Rob
what's going on Dr John it's a privilege
and an honor to be on the best mental
health uh and and relationship podcast
it's catching on brother that's awesome
thanks Rob what's up dude
how can I help man so uh my question was
uh how do I identify what my needs are
uh in relationship to marriage
relationships work Ministry Etc dude
that's a dope question all right so how
can you identify what your needs are
tell me more
so basically
um about two years ago I started the
journey into bettering my mental and
emotional health
and I realized
um I've never been asked
you know the question you always ask in
your podcast which is you know sit down
with your wife and ask what are your
needs these are my needs and uh I've
tried that with my wife and when she
asked me she's very straight to the
point hey I need you to clean this do
this I got the garbage and when she asks
me I just draw a blank I'm not used to
being asked what it means I'm used to
supply the needs ah man dude
you're an absolute Rock Star Rob
uh I was growing up hard or was it
um pretty smooth sailing
uh it was pretty tough yeah
you spent a lot of your life making sure
everybody else is all right
haven't you
correct yes sir okay
and there's honor and Valor in that and
there's Beauty in that and it's finite
because the longer you go without
changing the oil and without giving
yourself a checkup and without changing
the tires
the shorter the life is right and so
your ability to help others and to love
others and to do well for other people
is shortened if you don't take care of
yourself if you don't understand what
your needs are and ask for help in
meeting those things I can't tell you
how proud I am of you man
it's you're asking the million dollar
question and I'm so proud of you
um I also want to challenge your wife
and she's not on the phone so
she's given you a series of tasks
all right like a series of things that
she is like a honeydew list
I'm gonna suggest needs are deeper than
that okay
so here's the way
um you can find those needs here's all I
want you to do
get a small you have a like a like a
smartphone
yes all right cool just keep the notes
app on your phone open
and I want you to start writing down
when you get mad
when you get angry when you get sad when
you get frustrated right
your emotions are signals
and for you when you shut down I want
you to write that down
what just happened that makes you check
out that makes your body going to
neutral
what makes you want to hit somebody in
the mouth
what makes you want to just back up and
have another beer or back up and just
head out of the house because she's
going again or he's going to get
whatever's going on
your emotions are signals
and it's just simply learning to read
it's like you're in a new country and
you you don't know the language and you
see all these signs along the road and
you just need to learn what the signs
say that's what we're doing here okay
and your body is a great signaler and
most people in your situation have spent
their entire lives learning how to shut
those signals off
so they can just be about getting the
job done so people quit hassling them
is that fair
yes sir okay
when your body begins to say every time
somebody comes at me I shut down
that's a need
hey honey
whenever you get really mad at me I shut
down and I'm working on it
but if you need something from me I'm
gonna ask can you just write it down for
a season and put it on this little note
card for me
or when I come in the door and the first
thing you start doing is starting
rattling off 15 things I need to get
done today
I need you when we when I walk in the
door can you just
um holler at me and I'll come find you
and we can just hug for five seconds it
just helps calm me down a little bit
your hugs bring me peace be a gift to me
that's what I'm looking at okay or I
need 10 minutes when I walk in the door
just to transition from my job
to my home I just need 10 minutes can I
have 10 minutes
and those are where you start uncovering
what your needs are okay
and here's where it's going to get
really hard
a couple of them you're going to be
embarrassed about
you're going to feel ashamed of
like I did when I asked my wife hey
occasionally can you just tell me that
you're proud of me because I'm doing all
this for you
and that was embarrassing for me to say
out loud
um some men desperately need
sex but some men desperately need their
wife like the person who loves them just
to hold their hand
sit by him
not ask for anything just be with and
that sounds very unmasculine it sounds
very like oh my gosh are you serious yes
I'm serious so whatever your needs
happen to be that's what they happen to
be hey can we just watch a show together
can we go for a walk together right and
the more you look listen to your body
send your signals through these emotions
these feelings whatever
the closer you're gonna get to it
how's that sound
that sounds uh sounds good sounds uh
plain easy to follow yeah it is but
there's layers to it okay so there's
gonna come a season when you keep
thinking the floor is falling out from
under you
you're gonna think you've got it and
then you're gonna get really mad about
something and it's that moment when you
can go ah okay what's my body trying to
tell me here
or you're gonna just get up to go get
another piece of cake or another donut
and then another donut you're gonna ask
yourself okay what's my body trying to
tell me here I may just need some sleep
I may just need to go to exercise for 30
minutes or I may need to sit down and
have a hard conversation with my wife
that makes sense
yes sir and the next time y'all sit down
and have this conversation I'm dude I'm
so freaking proud of you for even having
this conversation
next time you sit down and she starts
rattling off I need you to paint this I
need you to get the dishes up I need you
to fix get the trash taken out I want
you to say
excellent those are a series of tasks I
can do I can do those jobs
beneath that though sweetheart what do
you need from me
do you need me to be more present
give me to work less
do you mean a shower more like what do
you need from me
because I'm gonna lean in and she's
going to give you a couple of needs
they're going to make you feel
uncomfortable and again that discomfort
that's your body's sending you a signal
what is it
what's your body trying to tell you so
this is a one two three year Journey
you're on now man to actually start
asking yourself what do I need and
here's what's really fun about needs
they shift and they change they move and
that makes them fun right when you think
you got them
you know what I need less touch in this
season I need more exercise you know I
need less exercise in the season anymore
sleep you know I need I need more just
let's go on dates I need less dates I
just need more wild rambunctious sex you
know what I need less crazy sex and I
need more boring married person sex just
straight up boring connectivity whatever
it looks like man it's getting in touch
with that cycle that you're gonna have
and needs and needs and needs and it
becomes such a fun adventure to do with
your spouse
so fun because her needs shift your need
shift and the goal becomes not trying to
hold those needs stable
but it becomes man how can I
meet those needs that's a fun adventure
man doesn't get much more fun than that
brother I'm proud of you rob keep
getting to know yourself keep getting to
know your wife man y'all are in for a
fun fun adventure